Hãy đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé!
nhằm nâng cao và phát triển sự chiến học máy
và mục tiêu của em sẽ là các mô hình tấn công SQL Injection
thì em xin phép vào phần đặt vấn đề
hiện trạng là dữ liệu tấn công SQL Injection trong tập huấn luyện bị mất cân bằng nghiêm trọng
thường là lớp ATTACK sẽ có tỷ lệ ít hơn lớp NORMAL rất là nhiều
Nên mục tiêu của em là sẽ sinh ra thêm dữ liệu SQL, injection tổng hợp
Và vừa có thể giữ được đúng cấu trúc SQL, vừa có tính đa dạng và cũng sẽ cải thiện Recall Look Attack
Thì đầu tiên là em sẽ có 4 mô hình
Thì đầu tiên là nhóm phương pháp Baylight
Thì đại diện sẽ là SMOD
Thì cơ chế sẽ chỉ là nội sinh để có thể sinh ra dữ liệu
Tiếp theo là 3 nhóm tạo mô hình sinh dữ liệu
sẽ gồm có GAN cơ bản, CT GAN và mô hình SQL GAN
Đây là mô hình GAN cơ bản
Mô hình GAN cơ bản sẽ là sự đối kháng giữa Generator và Discriminator
Mô hình CT GAN thay vì nhận dữ liệu trực tiếp
thì sẽ biến đổi thành các dạng bảng để có thể dễ dàng tính toán gradient để có thể tìm hướng để cải thiện mô hình
Còn mô hình Sequence GAN thì là thay vì sử dụng dạng bảng thì sẽ sử dụng Policy Gradient
Tiếp theo là sẽ đến với các mức cân bằng mà em dùng để thử nghiệm
Em sẽ có 3 mức độ cân bằng
Mức cân bằng thì đầu tiên là mức độ nhẹ là 1 trên 10 và 1 trên 20
nghĩa là cứ có 1 mẫu tấn công
à cứ có 20 mẫu
bình thường thì sẽ có ít nhất 1 mẫu tấn công
và tương tự với 1 trên 50
1 trên 100
1 trên 200 và 1 trên 500
em sẽ chọn lấy
trong quá trình triển khai
thì em nhận thấy là
mẫu 1 trên 10 và 1 trên 20
thì có khá nhiều mẫu attack
và có tỷ lệ nó khá là tốt
trong khi đó là mẫu
1 trên 50 và 1 trên 100
thì nó lại vừa cân bằng
nghĩa là nó có đủ độ khó khăn
để em có thể nhìn thấy được ra kết quả
thế nên trong mô hình thì em
ra loại, loại đi các mức độ nhẹ
và chỉ tập trung vào mức độ trung bình và cao
Thế thì hỏi là cái phân loại
nhẹ trung bình cao là em tự phân loại hay là
có bài làm ra không ạ?
Em tự phân loại
Vâng em tự phân loại bởi thứ nhất là
trong mô hình thì thường là
mức độ nhẹ là em lại không đủ dữ liệu
một số dạng tấn công ví dụ như là
Thì khi mà em chạy là nó không đủ dữ liệu để em có thể chạy được tỷ lệ 1 trên 10
Và khi mà em chạy thì em cảm thấy là tỷ lệ 1 trên 10, 1 trên 20 nó không đóng góp quá nhiều
Và nó lại khá tốn thời gian để training
Nên là em đã loại bỏ và chỉ tập trung vào 4 tỷ lệ còn lại
Các em có bài báo nào đang chia như thế này không?
em sẽ về tìm hiểu. Nhưng mà trong các bài báo em đọc thì em em chưa gặp bài báo nào chia như
tỷ lệ của em. Em sẽ về tìm hiểu thêm ạ. Thì tiếp theo là em sẽ dựa trên bốn chỉ số đánh giá chất
lượng ạ. Thì đầu tiên là structure ạ. Là kiểm tra xem là có dấu hiệu SQL không ạ. Thì mục tiêu của
em là kiểm tra xem là payload còn giữ được hình dạng của SQL injection hay không. Tiếp theo là
là độ độc nhất là em sẽ so khớp đến từng ký tự xem là bị trùng bao nhiêu phần trăm do với dữ liệu đổ vào
tiếp theo là Overlap là lần này em sẽ làm mở rộng hơn là không từng ký tự mà là các cụm từ, các cụm câu để xem là trùng bao nhiêu phần trăm
và cuối cùng là tính Recall để xem là liệu là có các cái phương pháp liệu có tăng hoặc là giảm bức Recall hay không
Có cái dấu gì Delta để trước dịp Recon?
Delta Recon là giữa Bayline trừ đi cả iWomen
là sự thay đổi của Recon
Delta Recon là gì? Mọi người biết không?
Em lấy Recon của mẫu tính đầu vào
sau đó trừ đi, sau khi mà sinh ra thì em lại tính thêm 1 lần Random Forest nữa để trừ đi
Đấy là tiếng Việt nhé, không phải tiếng Anh
Thì đây là em sẽ tiến hành khảo sát ban đầu
Quay lại trước
Rồi quay lại sau
Thì tự nhiên nhảy vào nguồn vụ tiên ra
Chỉ số đây đúng không?
Vâng
Lúc trước nó quả nguồn vụ tiên hoặc là gì?
Nó là trùng lập
Đây là nguồn vụ tiên
Cột này em đang chưa
Dự kiện nha
Dự kiện
Nó dựa vào AI nhiều quá
Thì tiếp
Vâng thì là nguồn vụ tiên
theo là em sẽ đề xuất là sẽ có 2 hướng cải thiện
à vâng
thì đầu tiên là
3 mô hình đầu tiên
thì là do là chỉ là nội sinh
và cũng học
khá là
nó không cố gắng sinh ra dữ liệu mới
mà nó chỉ học từ dữ liệu cũ
nên là 3 mô hình đầu tiên
thì có structure
giống hệt S-Penetration
có mô hình sinh quần găng gốc
thì là do cố gắng học các mối quan hệ
nên là sinh ra dữ liệu thì có cấu trúc nó sẽ không thể được bằng 3 mềm còn lại
tuy nhiên là tỷ lệ sinh ra dữ liệu độc nhất thì nó sẽ cao hơn
hai cuộc cuối em sẽ về em chỉnh lại
cái này em chưa được chỉnh hết
nhưng mà em muốn nói là sau khi mà chạy xong khám xác ban đầu
thì em có thể nhận thấy là 3 mềm còn lại là về nếu mà tiếp tục sử dụng
Thì nó cũng sẽ chỉ có khả năng là dựa vào bộ
dữ liệu cũ và nó không có khả năng sinh ra dữ liệu có tính mới
Và rất dễ có thể bị bắt và có thể bị đánh chặn
Trong khi đó là mô hình si quần gan
Thì là tuy là hiện tại nó không sinh ra được mẫu có cấu trúc SQL
Nhưng mà nó lại sinh ra các mẫu có độ độc nhất cao
Nên là em sử dụng mô hình si quần gan và cố gắng cải tiến để tăng khả năng sinh dữ liệu của mô hình si quần gan
Thì em có 2 hướng đề xuất
Thì đầu tiên là sẽ cải thiện dữ liệu là phân phối lại dữ liệu đầu vào
Thì đầu tiên là em sẽ chia ra làm 3 trường hợp tấn công
À 4 trường hợp tấn công thì sẽ gồm có Union, Boland, Time và Erin
Em sẽ tách input theo từng đặc trưng để có
Theo từng family để mô hình tạo sinh có thể học được đúng pattern của từng loại
Tránh bị trống chéo giữa các family heat train
Tiếp theo là em sẽ chuẩn hóa độ dài input về các khoảng hợp lý
Tránh cho việc generator học lệch theo một vài mẫu hiếm
Thiện tiện thứ 2 là hướng thuật toán
Mục tiêu của em là muốn mô hình lần này sẽ học đúng cấu trúc SQL thay vì chỉ đánh lừa discriminator
Tiếp theo em sẽ tokenize từng unit riêng thay vì tách từng ký tự trần
Giúp generator học pháp dễ hơn
Và cuối cùng là em sẽ bổ sung phương pháp chấm điểm payload với mục tiêu là kiểm tra dữ liệu sinh ra có đúng khủng pháp SQL không
Và em sẽ cộng thẳng reward này và update vào generator
Đầu tiên em sẽ đến với 6 kịch bản cải thiện dữ liệu
Thì trong đó kịch bản A là em sẽ vẫn giữ nguyên phương phong cách em lựa chọn cũ sau lúc chạy đồ vào để coi như là mốc ban đầu
Tiếp theo là em sẽ chọn ưu tiên là các ký tự ngắn
C là em sẽ ưu tiên độ dài phổ biến, trung vị
D là em sẽ random không hoàn lại trong vùng trung vị
Em sẽ bỏ 25% đầu và 75% cuối và chỉ tập trung vào 50% ở giữa
Tiếp theo là em sẽ random cho toàn bộ dữ liệu
Và em sẽ giữ chỉ số random trong toàn bộ mô hình này là 88
Để đảm bảo là tính đồng nhất
Và cuối cùng là em sẽ chọn theo phương án...
Em sẽ chọn theo phương án...
Em chọn theo...
Để một tí ạ. Cái này em đang...
Để tiếng Anh em sẽ viết nó ạ.
Nhưng mà em muốn nói là cái phương pháp N này là em sẽ cố gắng chọn để có thể lấy được đa dạng nhất có thể các cái tí tự.
Thì em sẽ chọn theo phương án...
Chọn theo phương án 3 gram.
Tiếp theo là hướng cải thiện thuật toán
sẽ có 3 hướng, đầu tiên là em sẽ tokenize hóa các dữ liệu SQL
thay vì để những dữ liệu có chung ý nghĩa
em sẽ tokenize hóa để tránh việc mô hình vốn học những mẫu
sinh ra những mẫu đặc biệt mà không có ý nghĩa
Tiếp theo là tăng Pre-Chain, em sẽ tăng Pre-Chain từ 120 lên 160 để tránh bị Collapse và cũng làm cho mô hình Pre-Chain Trayator vững chãi hơn
Và cuối cùng là em sẽ tăng thưởng điểm Rewards
Thay vì em để 100% là Disc Creator Rewards thì em sẽ để 70% là Disc Miner Rewards
và 30% còn lại sẽ là SQL SPA REWARD để có thể mong dữ liệu sinh ra được
có cấu trúc SQL hơn ạ
và đây là tổng là sẽ có 8 kịch bản
2 mục 3
thì là sẽ có là 8 kịch bản
thì sau khi mà áp dụng tất cả các kịch bản đồng thời
thì em sẽ có các cái đánh giá
Đây là mô hình mà có điểm cấu trúc cao nhất
là mô hình thiên nhiên
Bây giờ lại thành Dominant rồi
Bây giờ lại Dominant rồi
Nếu mà tìm đồ gì thì tìm đồ quý đấy nhé
Vâng
Đây là các cái mô hình cấu trúc
các cái kết quả mô hình ạ
thì ở đây sẽ
trong mô hình này thì kịch bản là BV8
là kịch bản mà chiếm gần như đa số
đa số đứng top đầu như đa số trong các lĩnh vực trong đó sẽ có hai kịch bản là cũng đứng top là
sẽ gồm có Bolin dv7 và Union dv2 thì sau đó dựa vào thông số trên ạ thì em đề xuất là cộng cộng
là sẽ có 11 kịch bản em lựa chọn để chạy ạ thì đầu tiên là ứng viên thứ nhất là sẽ là dv8 như em
Tiếp theo là ứng viên số 2 là các kịch bản cũng nằm ở trong top đã được đề xuất ở bên trên
Và ứng viên số 3 là em sẽ chọn để có thể lấy mẫu để có thể so sánh
Thì ở Poland, trong kết quả thực tế là mô hình V8 và V7 là chiếm vị trí rất là cao và bỏ xa
So với các kết quả khác
Em sẽ chọn lấy
Phần top 3 để em ưu tiên
Tính ngẫu nhiên
Còn đối với kịch bản Aaron
Lỗi thì em sẽ chọn
V4 bởi vì là
Mũ hình này cũng nằm trong top 3
Và cũng có chỉ số ổn định
Tương tự với cả A
V8 thì đối với kịch bản Time
Là nó đặc biệt hơn
Bởi vì là nó cần phải
Nó cần phải học được
Nó cần phải biết được chính xác được
được cả là các ngữ pháp cho từng database riêng nên là trong kịch bản Time này thì chỉ có 3 mô
hình là không bị collapse đến cuối. Và cuối cùng đến kịch bản Union thì là em sẽ chọn Fv3 là ưu
tiên sự đa dạng. Đây là kết quả cuối cùng. Đầu tiên là kết quả với các mô hình cơ bản, 4 mô
Mô hình cơ bản ban đầu thì ở đây là các mô hình, 3 mô hình đầu thì vẫn như cũ là cũng sẽ có tỷ lệ học được cấu trúc SQL rất là cao.
Tuy nhiên là độ unique của nó là không hề tăng và chỉ số recall cũng không tăng quá nhiều và có một vài mô hình bị giảm rất là cao.
Trong khi đó còn các mô hình mà em đề xuất
Thì em đưa ra kết quả của top 5 mô hình tốt nhất
Thì là mô hình DV
Nếu mà sử dụng kịch bản DV8 cho yêu nhiệt
Thì sẽ là tốt nhất có thể
Tương tự với cả Bolin là DV7
Time là DV8
Error là DV3
Thì em kết luận là
Đối với các mô hình cơ bản, độ độc nhất sẽ bị giảm dần nếu như càng tăng mức tỷ lệ càng khắc nhiệt thì độ unique sẽ càng càng giảm
Điểm cấu trúc sẽ luôn rất cao nhưng tỷ lệ trùng lọc cũng đồng thời rất cao
Còn so sánh giữa mô hình si quần góc và si quần cải tiến của em
lần này là em đã thật sự sinh ra chuỗi mới
và bản gốc thì structure đã sụp đổ và bị collapse
khi mà tiến đến tới tỷ lệ 1 trên 50
còn bản của em là vẫn có thể sinh ra dữ liệu
và khả năng cân bằng tốt hơn
và trong đó là sẽ có 2 kịch bản tốt nhất
đó chính là Union thì sẽ sử dụng kịch bản DV8
và Bowden là kịch bản DV7
thì đây cuối cùng là em sẽ đưa vào mô hình tương lượng thực tế
còn đây là các thiết lập của em
thì là khi mà đưa vào thì là sẽ có tỷ lệ bị chặn là 70% trên toàn bộ
và tỷ lệ không bị chặn là 3%
mà sau khi mà em đọc em xem các cái kết quả thực tế
thì em nhận ra là hầu hết cái tỷ lệ không bị chặn này là do là nó dịch ra dữ liệu nhiễu
Nó thật sự không có tác dụng tấn công
Nên nó có khả năng vượt qua được tường lửa
Thế nên là em sẽ
show luôn dữ liệu payload thực tế để phân tích ạ.
Thì đây là đối với mô hình SMODE ạ. Thì ở đây các mẫu sinh ra rất là tốt ạ.
Tuy nhiên là nó sinh ra khá nhiều các mẫu có khoảng trắng và một vài mẫu bị lệch kỹ thuật ạ.
Nghĩa là nếu mà đối với một số mẫu mà yêu cầu về ngữ pháp khá là cao
Ví dụ như Timeline chẳng hạn là rất dễ có thể bị lệch kỹ thuật
Bởi vì nó chỉ biết ghép chứ nó không học được các mối quan hệ
Thế tương tự
Tôi có thể hỏi cái điểm chéo Warp là gì?
Trong này là điểm 100 là đánh giá
Đây là điểm đánh giá xem là có phải là mẫu SQL không
Còn Warp ở đây là kết quả trả về sau khi mà đưa vào tấn công
Là HTTP 403 ở đây là không có kết quả trả về
Tiếp theo là đối với mô hình gan thì nó cũng bị giống như với mô hình smooth thì nó cũng có bít trùng lặp
và một số các cái mô hình
à một số các cái phan đi
mà yêu cầu ngữ pháp cao
thì là nó cũng không học được
nó cũng không học được mà
nó chỉ biết lặp lại
mà nó không học được mối quan hệ ngữ pháp
đối với mô hình CT gan
thì là cũng bị vấn đề như vậy
còn mô hình CT gan
thì như ở trên thông số
là nó thật sự đã học được
cấu trúc nhưng mà khi mà
càng ngày mà càng khắc nhiệt
Kỷ lệ khắc nhật thì nó sẽ cố gắng tìm tới những cái mẫu mà cơ bản và càng ngắn bởi vì nó ưu tiên an toàn.
Mã 200 là vượt qua được ạ.
Có không? Vượt qua nhưng mà nó không có ý nghĩa gì cả đúng không?
Ví dụ như là mã đầu là có tấn công được ạ.
Như bắt đầu có tấn công được nhưng mà nó sẽ chỉ cố gắng là sinh ra những mẫu siêu ngắn bởi vì nó bị collapse và cố gắng ép tới những cái trường hợp mà thật sự an toàn
Thì đến cuối cùng là mô hình cải tiến là nó đã sửa được những gì mà mô hình si quần gan gốc của em gặp vấn đề là nó đã sinh ra dữ liệu dài hơn
Tuy nhiên là nó cũng khi mà gặp những cái kịch bản family mà nó yêu cầu mức pháp quá khắc khe
như là Time và Alien thì nó cũng không học được củ pháp ạ.
Thế nên là trong toàn bộ mô hình của em chỉ có đúng 2 mô hình
là DV8 đối với Poland và DV7 đối với Union
là thật sự sinh ra kết quả tốt và có khả năng ứng dụng được đấy ạ.
Còn 11 kịch bản còn lại thì thật sự là không có kịch bản nào
có thể sinh ra dữ liệu mà có thể sử dụng được.
sẽ đưa đến quyết luận là mô hình của em đã giải quyết được những vấn đề mà mô hình SQL GAN cũ đã gặp phải
nhưng mà tuy nhiên trên thực tế là sẽ chỉ có 2 kịch bản Union và Boland là nó thật sự học được
do là yếu tố yêu cầu về ngữ pháp của nó sẽ thấp hơn so với 2 family còn lại
và 2 family còn lại là kết quả của em là không có quá nhiều cải thiện
Cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi và hẹn gặp lại.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Nó là kết hợp giữa cả là dữ liệu và thuật toán, dữ liệu sẽ là kịch bản B và D, còn thuật toán là kịch bản B8, thì em có đưa 2 cái bản ở đây.
Nếu như mấy loại xe cuốn gan bình thường, xe cuốn gan và xe cuốn gan ở đằng kia thì nó là cái gì mà mua hay không?
Em xin lỗi thầy, nhưng em chưa ý thức được câu hỏi của thầy ạ.
Thì nghĩa là bây giờ em nên viết ra tổng hợp là kịch bản DV8 và DV7 của em là thật sự có những cái gì hay là gì nào?
Không phải, em dở lại cái mô hình của cái xe cuốn gan.
Rồi, đây.
Đấy, trong mô hình này thì em đã tìm cái gì?
Thì trong mô hình này, em cải thiện 3 cái
Đầu tiên là em sẽ tăng thông số pre-chain lên từ 120 lên 160
Để cho mô hình generator sẽ có vững hơn để tránh bị collapse
Tiếp theo là em sẽ có reward thay vì để 100% là distributor reward
thì em sẽ để là 70% thôi ạ
và em sẽ thêm 30% reward của SQL
để mong là mô hình có sinh ra được cấu trúc dòng SQL hơn ạ
Ví dụ như em bảo là có 3 cải tiến
thì cải tiến thứ nhất thì có thử và ra kết quả nó hơn so với phía cũ không?
Cải tiến thứ 2 thì có thử và ra kết quả nó hơn so với phía cũ không?
Ờ em có ạ
Thì em sẽ chạy toàn bộ luôn ạ
là em sẽ áp dụng tổng cộng
Từ từ đã đi đây, tôi muốn hỏi là cái sức khỏe gian của em, em nghĩ cái gì ý đâu ạ?
Em không vẽ vào mô hình ở đây ạ.
Thầy nhập tóc hiểu được.
À rồi, em hiểu như thế.
Nó là sức khỏe gian đúng không?
Sức khỏe gian đẹp đến là không.
Chưa có đúng không ạ?
Vâng ạ, em chưa có mô hình.
Thì cái thật chính của em là cái phần trình bày về cái sức khỏe nguồn cảnh thì em phải nói rõ là phải cải thiện như gì.
Trước cải thiện như thế này và sau cải thiện kết quả như thế nào.
Kết quả bình thường là bạn có sinh ra như thế này và sau khi sinh ra như thế này, các thầy chỉ có đợi ở đấy thôi.
Có bảo vệ, có những lời không để lên nữa thì tốt để lấy trong đó. Chưa hiểu được sinh ra là gì, sao thì hiểu sao.
Cảm ơn thầy.
Thầy tiếp theo.
Có đó.
Em không...
Thầy,
là tỷ lệ
Cải thiện cái gì thay cũng chả hiểu, cải thiện cái gì đâu
Ở mức độ kinh nghiệm thì cái cải thiện chỉ là để các thành thường hiểu cho em
Thì còn chứ không cần trình bày phải cải thiện đâu, em hiểu chưa?
Thì đấy là nội dung của kinh nghiệm
Nhưng mà cái trình bày của em vừa rồi cũng dối quá là mọi người không hiểu
Thì thay cũng chưa hiểu đâu
Bây giờ anh tập trung vào một cái tầm mồm là từ cái SQL, bây giờ em sinh ra một cái SQL, đó là một cái cách thức để em đề xuất,
thì em tập trung vào cái việc mà em gọi là để sinh ra.
Trong những cái sinh ra đấy thì em cũng đề xuất là có một cái mô hình mà em muốn gọi là cho nó mất hơn những cái mô hình bình thường.
Thì còn hai cái đấy thôi, thì chúng ta hiểu được là chúng ta tổng thân là tổng thân sinh ra cái SQL Edition.
Và trong các cái mô hình em sử dụng SQL Edition thì em sử dụng trên cả mô hình là SQL GAM và có một phần kiểm nghiệm thôi.
Thế thôi. Nghĩa là nó kiểm tra được những lợi ích gì.
Thế thôi.
Nếu thầy nghĩa là vệt bản và...
Bây giờ em mở quyển luật văn ra xin mở ra cho thầy xem cái chỗ nào là thầy đi.
Có ý thầy bảo em là thầy có ý thầy đi vào.
Slide này cũng chưa phản ánh được cái góp ý lần trước.
Rồi trình bày lại nhiều cái chuyện là đây là cái nhóm mà sinh nhật chưng, đây là cái nhóm sinh chuối.
Đúng không? Lần trước thầy đã góp ý rất nhiều rồi cũng chưa thấy thay đổi bao nhiêu cả.
Đề án mình tập trung vào nghiên cứu về dùng mạng gan để hỗ trợ sinh sinh dữ liệu
Thì em hình dung là cái chuyện em tìm hiểu
Citygan hay Citygan đấy là nó góp rồi
Thì trong tìm hiểu đấy mình nói là mình phân biệt ra 2 loại
Một là sinh liệt chức
Sinh liệt chức là ra cái thứ mà không ai hiểu là cái gì cả
Nhưng mà đưa vào cái mô hình máy thì nó vẫn nhận
Cái anh ta là sinh hẳn cái chú ý thật
Anh ta bảo Citygan là sinh rất là chú ý thật
Cái này thầy cũng đang chưa hiểu
Đúng ạ. Thì là gan với cả CD gan là nó cũng chỉ sinh đặc trưng vào xây quần gan thì là...
Đúng thế. Cái vấn đề là em cứ tập trung cái chuyện cải tiến này, cải tiến là đấy là làm hết.
Mình trình bày cái mặt chính luôn, tốt đi đã. Đúng không?
Thay là nói đồ ăn về cái mạng gan. Thế trước đây em trình bày mạng gan ở chỗ nào nhỉ? Đúng chưa?
Trước đây trình bày mạng gan, gan cấu trúc những thành phần như thế nào, hàm lót xuất như thế nào. Đúng không?
Tại sao dùng gan để xin dữ liệu?
Chứ nếu em cứ nhảy vào thì cải thiện luôn, hóa ra đầy dài phải đi vào là trọng tâm em cải thiện ra không?
Chưa vẽ mô hình, em cũng chỉ vẽ là lưu đồ thật toán.
Cần về cái gì em phải cải thiện.
Về xem lại đi.
Vâng.
Có 1 cái slide cho mà hơn 1 tuần rồi em cũng thử lại cái này rồi.
Em có 1 phần thử nghiệm với tường lửa phải không?
Dạ.
Nhưng mà cái đấy thì có cái mẫu nào mà đúng tốt đấy mà thân hiệp gọi quản được không?
Có, có 157 mẫu, nhưng mà trong lúc thuyết trình em cảm giác là em đang bị nói hơi không đúng trọng tâm nha em đã
Cái này em hơi thắc mắc tại vì là thường các cái tường lửa và ứng dụng thì ví dụ như nó bắt câu lệnh thì nó bắt theo cấu trúc rồi
Tức là cái đoạn thay hội theo số thì chúng ta vẫn biết tại vì nó tuân thuyết cấu trúc rất lớn nhỉ
bình thường cái tên ngựa mà đi bắt một câu đấy xí lệch thì nó đi qua
thì nó sẽ thường cũng đã biết cái cấu trúc vừa rồi
còn cái thay tham số thì nó vẫn bắt lại
trong mô hình của em là em sử dụng cái phương án nó không cao cấp
và nó khá đặc trà là most security và rule là OAV
nên là với cả em cũng không có xây dựng cái DB nó quá là đầy đủ
Ví dụ như chỉ cần tấn công vượt qua mà báo về mẫu 200 mà lúc đấy em sẽ ngồi đọc payload xem là có các đặc tính
Nếu mà đưa vào thực tế thì có thể nó sẽ không khai thác được quá nhiều
Thế là đây là em có cao tiền với cái mẫu 200
Em không thay đổi, em tải rồi em sử dụng lại nên không thay đổi trong quá trình chạy học
Nó có 2 kiểu trường hợp, một là dữ liệu sinh ra nó không theo cấu trúc của SQL vượt qua được
hoặc là cũng nhiễu đúng không?
Đúng ạ
Cái đó là nếu nó tốt như cấu trúc thì cái tham số trong đấy nó phải như nào đó đúng không?
Phải có giá trị địa tấn công đúng không?
Vâng
Cái đấy mình hỏi là cái đấy có sinh ra cả đám kia thế như thế không để vượt qua tấn công không?
Vượt qua tầng lửa của tấn công không?
Nếu vượt qua tường lửa của em, trong mô hình của em, nếu vượt qua được 200
Lúc đấy em sẽ thật sự vào để em đọc và xem có cấu trúc
Còn nếu yêu cầu trong môi trường thực tế, tường lửa của các doanh nghiệp thì chắc chắn là không vượt qua
Cái mô security của nó khá là mạnh, sinh cái streamer SQL và đưa theo
Bản chất của nó chỉ là theo cái tham số thôi chứ đúng không?
Không nghĩa là bởi vì trong chính cái kịch bản của em ạ, nó cũng không có database ạ, nó chỉ đơn giản là đưa vào bộ lọc và nếu như trả về kết quả 200 thì em sẽ biết là một là nó đã vượt qua hoặc là noise, lúc đấy em bắt đầu mới đọc xem là nó có cấu trúc SV ạ, còn em trong mô hình này em không có thử nhận xem có tấn công được để em không.
Nếu mà đạt về 200 nó trả lời nó hoạt động, những khu vực này bình thường thì nó vẫn hoạt động của mình trong cơ sở thì có gì nó sẽ hoàn thành được để đạt ra đợt tổng hợp SRL?
Đúng rồi. Thì là trong mô hình thì mình chỉ tập trung vào việc là một cái câu SRL, Injection có cấu trúc SRL khi đeo qua tường lửa và trả về kết quả 200
Chứ nó không bị chặn 403. Thì mình sẽ chỉ tập trung khai thác những cái thông tin như thế
nghĩa là AFL có sự tuyên bẩn và có sự tỉnh đại
có sự tỉnh đại thì cứ xử lý được mình mới có gì để cho nó ra ra được
rồi
người ta chỉ cần phát hiện được thôi
cái câu lệnh mà đi qua mà theo những kiểu tấn công để xem nó sinh ra như thế nào
không có chuyện khác
nghĩa là nếu mà câu lệnh này chính phẩm AFL thì mình chỉ cần kiểm thử được
vì mình có thể phản định câu lệnh này là AFL chính phẩm tuyên bẩn
mình là nhắn một tay cả hẳn
nhưng mà bản thân nó có phải tự tin cho AFL là một nền để tương ứng
thế thì vấn đề nó cũng hỏi đấy
Bộ dữ liệu này có tấn công đa dạng trên nhiều DB và nó cũng yêu
cũng yêu cầu các cái đầu vào payload và các cái cấu trúc là nó khác biệt chứ nó không tưởng chung một cái cú pháp
Thế nên là trước là mình cũng có làm là cũng có xây dựng lên nhưng mà là do là phải thêm thấp những cái HTTP phải chuẩn thì lúc đó nó thật sự ảnh hưởng
nên là lúc đấy là mình mới bỏ phương án đấy và mình chỉ quan tâm việc là có vượt qua được bộ rule set và có trả về 200 hay không
Nếu mà xây dựng như Lam nói thì khả năng cao là sẽ không vượt qua được thật
Nhưng mà giả sử nếu cần phải làm chia sẻ mức đấy thì sẽ phải viết từng cái cấu trúc để cho từng cái tài loại một và đưa vào
Chứ không thể kiểu sửa ứng dụng đại trà được
Thì đấy là vấn đề mà mình gặp phải về cái đưa vào từng lượng
Thế là mục tiêu này là sinh ra dữ liệu kiểm công không? Kiểm thử dễ công không?
Đúng
Còn có thể là test thử với bộ phát hiện người mốt sinh ra dữ liệu không để test thử xem
Cũng làm, cũng hạ hạ xuống
Vì lúc đầu cũng đúng như anh với cả Lao nói là cũng muốn là thật sự xem là tường lửa có được không
Trong lúc triển khai thì phải tự nhiên nó phức tạp hơi nhiều so với mục tiêu ban đầu
Và cảm giác nó hơi lệch nên là mới thu nhỏ xuống
Nó chỉ đơn giản là chỉ cần trả về mẫu 200 sau khi vượt qua đổi thu xét, kiểm tra xem có dùng SVL Injection hay không, hay là nhiễu
Nếu như là SVL Injection thì sẽ đưa vào luôn
Mẫu tấn công này có đặc tính SVL Injection chứ không nhằm tới việc là có thật sự định nghĩa và khai thác thực tế
Mình về trình bày lại cho rõ trong văn lẫn, trong slide nhé
Đấy, thứ nhất thầy nói thì bạn phải lấy cường để ghi như thầy nói cả
Trước đây có bị ít rồi, tuần này có lệch
Thứ hai là đầu tiên phải nói về cái bài thoáng phát hiện
Tấn công là chỉ quen với một section rất clear ở trên slide
Người ta đã từng làm gì thế nào?
Người ta đã từng làm gì?
Đấy chưa?
Cái work và cái detector nó là những cái gì?
Tiếp theo là liên quan tới sinh dữ liệu
Cơ bản người ta dùng SMOTE
Và trong luận văn này em tìm hiểu về một phương pháp sử dụng sinh dữ liệu
Thì gan nó là cái gì? Tại sao phải sử dụng gan?
Mình cứ nói cho không xuyên xoay
Và trong đoàn đề án này em tìm hiểu những mùi gan như sau
CT gan, CT cột gan
Được kết quả như thế này
Trình bày những phần bản đánh vọng thôi
Các thầy không thể hiểu các thầy làm cái gì lắm
Em dạng được kết quả như thế này
Chỉ phải đúng theo dựa dựa như thế này nhé
Đã được kết quả như thế này
Và em thấy với sinh quần ngoan, sinh quần gan
Thì nó khác cái gan kia nó là cái gì
Hai nhóm, một nhóm là sinh đặc trưng
Một nhóm là sinh sinh quần
Ví dụ nó như thế này
Ví dụ vào thành phần ngay trên slide
Sinh đặc trưng nó sinh cái gì
Sinh chuỗi nó như thế này
Với kết quả hiện nay sinh quần gan nó đạt được mức độ như thế này
Em thấy là nó chưa được tốt lắm
Như vậy em có một đề xuất thêm, cải thiện xịt bồn gan, xịt bồn gan và cải thiện cái gì phải nói rõ.
Và cuối cùng kết quả đạt được như thế nào?
Quay trước thôi, em phải sửa làm sao để phản ảnh hiểu được.
Chưa, em hãy bổ sung giải thích câu hỏi này dầu quá.